quantum computing is a whole new
category of computing and it directly
leverages the laws of quantum mechanics
to do a computation as we all know
quantum quantum mechanics are the most
fundamental laws in the universe
it describes how everything in the
universe works so what we've built and
what other quantum computing researchers
have done is create computers that
directly use those laws of quantum
mechanics and that sounds fairly
straightforward but in fact it's quite
difficult to do because the enemy of
quantum computing is the environment so
you and when I say the environment I
mean things like temperature when you
have temperature you have molecules
moving around that cause interference to
the quantum computation you also have
electromagnetic interference from radio
sources and gamma rays and all sorts of
things so you need to create a very
quiet clean cold environment for these
these chips to work in and ultimately
what we're building is a quantum
computer on a chip that's about the size
of your fingernail in this very exotic
environment so that that environment
runs at near absolute zero so absolute
zero as you know is the lowest
temperature possible and in the universe
it so-called zero degrees Kelvin so
these machines run at a very low
temperature to so that they can have
that pristine very quick clean quiet
environment to run in it doesn't disturb
that quantum computation and in fact it
runs down at what's called 10
millikelvin which is 0.01 Kelvin
absolute zero is zero degrees Kelvin so
this is running at minus 270 3.14
degrees C and the lowest possible
temperature in physics is minus 273
point one five degrees C so very very
cold very very rarefied environment
because we're also running in a
effectively a magnetic vacuum so you
could consider these environments these
rigs that we built these systems that we
built to be probably the most rarefied
environments in the universe unless
there's other intelligent life in the
you
as you know pure colder environments for
instance outer space is 150 times warmer
than than the environment that we built
for these quantum computations so you
may ask why do we go through all this
trouble
the answer is the problems of quantum
computing is exponential speed ups over
classical computing for a particular set
of problems and that's very important
and exciting to researchers that are
working on a kind of human scale
problems ranging from things like
developing drugs for cancer or better
modeling the molecular interactions of
cancer and how it attacks cells and
things like that
two big data analysis looking for
patterns and and inferences and drawing
insight from large amounts of data or
doing things like better modeling
financial services markets and better
managing risk and so on so there's all
kind of applications that aren't
particularly well suited by today's type
of computers and I refer to today's
computers as classical computers they
they compute largely in the same way
they have for the past 60 or 70 years
since john von neumann and others
invented the first electronic computers
back in the 40s and we've had amazing
progress over those years think of all
the developments there have been in the
hardware side and in the software side
over those 60 or 70 years and how much
energy has been put energy and
development has been put into those
areas and we've achieved marvelous
things with that classical computing
environment but it has its limits too
and people sometimes ask why would we
need any more powerful computers these
applications these these problems that
we're trying to solve are incredibly
hard problems and aren't well suited for
the architecture of classical computing
so I see quantum computing as another
set of tools another resource set of
resources for scientists researchers
scientists programmers to develop and
enhance some of these capabilities to
really change the world in a much better
way than we're able to today with
classical computing it's not a
replacement for classical computing it
will be used in what I would call hybrid
approach where you're going to see both
the capability that's already been built
and high performance computing and other
types of computing markets working very
closely with quantum computing resources
one of the fundamental building blocks
or the fundamental building block of a
quantum computer is a thing called a
qubit qu bi T right so it's it's
basically a bit which is the lowest
level building block of a computer today
it's either 0 or 1 in digital terms
today with classical computing a qubit
has the interesting property of that it
can be in 0 & 1 as a digital bit can be
today but it can also be in what's
called the superposition of 0 1 1 in
other words it could be in two states 0
& 1 at the same time and our minds have
kind of difficulty understanding that
how can a particle or an object or qubit
how can it actually be in two states at
the same time you know it's just a very
foreign concept to to us but it's been
proven over and over it's a well
understood a characteristic of quantum
systems that they operate in in
superposition and entanglement is
another quantum mechanical property
that's that's well understood and a
little bit spooky but but certainly well
understood so these qubits are
interesting and you might think well
okay that's that's that's interesting I
can have 0 1 and the superposition of 0
and 1 at the same time but it only
really starts to get interesting when
you can string qubits together so if you
put say 512 of these qubits together as
we have in our latest generation
processor you can then represent 2 to
the number of qubits States
simultaneously so at the very beginning
of the computation in our computer we're
actually in 2 to the 512
States at the same time so two to the
512 is ten to the hundred and fifty
fourth power there's probably only
scientists estimate 10 to the 80th atoms
in the universe
so it's an absolutely astounding number
and it's indicative of the kind of
amazing things that go on regardless of
what type of quantum computer you have
when you have these qubits and you can
implement them and string them together
and couple them and entangle them you
see that you know as we grow the number
of qubits that capability grows very
dramatically and and but that's not a
caveat there that analogy is not
directly related to the performance that
you will see from this machine over time
because computing performance has a lot
of other characteristics that go along
with it namely the precision that you
can specify the problem the coupling
between qubits and all sorts of other
things so it's sort of like you know
Intel or others say you know their
integrated circuits have many billions
of transistors that's not a direct
implication to performance it's kind of
a metric or a rule of thumb and you know
the more transistors you have the more
capability but it's not directly related
to to performance so qubit is that
fundamental building block that's the
basis of all quantum computers so there
are different ways to build quantum
computers and and I would actually say
that quantum computing is really a
category of computing because there will
be many different types of quantum
computers that will be built over the
next decades there's basically the
theory and how you would build the
quantum computer and then there's the
implementation of how you do it and
those are sometimes two separate
separate things our computer uses a
theory that was developed at MIT in
roughly the year 2000 by ed Farhi and
team of researchers in the in the
physics department at MIT
it's called adiabatic quantum computing
it uses quantum annealing capability and
our founders believed that it was much
easier to implement this type of quantum
computer
it was also more robust against noise
some of those things that I talked about
trying to protect the environment from
the noise and the interference of the of
the environment that's really turned out
to be true the other types of quantum
computing the predominant one that
people are trying to implement today is
called gate model quantum computing
which is an entirely sensible way of
doing things because what you try to do
is is replicate digital gates which are
the building blocks of all computers
today and build quantum equivalents for
those gates
the problem with gate model computing is
it's exceptionally difficult to build
and there's a property called
decoherence meaning and basically the
interference from the outside
environment causes the computation to to
be shortened or short-lived and it
causes a lot of difficulty in building
large-scale quantum computers so the
largest gate model quantum computing
effort that's been done today I think is
factoring the number 21 7 and 7 and 3 as
we all know so it's a very small scale
kind of experiment kind of thing and
that really hasn't improved dramatically
over the last decade were d-wave with
its choice of adiabatic quantum
computing has been very effective at
solving real world problems at at real
scale there was another choice that
d-wave made that was equally as
important how you implement the type of
quantum computing so there's different
ways of actually building kind of the
substrate of quantum computing and that
can range from manipulating ions or
atomic particles at a very atomic scale
and obviously that could be difficult
but typically the way people do that is
by having lasers that energize a
particle and and manipulate the particle
in fact Dave Wineland who just won the
last year I believe won the Nobel Prize
in Physics for his work that was done
with ion trap quantum computing the
method that we chose is called
superconducting electronics and as you
may know superconducting electronics are
very low temperature
our electronics that exhibit this really
interesting property at very low levels
resistance goes to zero they they start
to superconduct and there are two
reasons why we use superconducting
electronics one is we needed to run at
that low temperature anyway to minimize
the interference from the environment
but also the this superconducting
technique has an interesting side effect
that's important that it generates no
heat
so as these computers scale as our
computer scales because we've
implemented superconducting the actual
heat dissipation of the chip doesn't
scale which is completely contrary to
all of computing that we know today that
becomes a huge energy drain and in fact
one of the largest consumers of
electricity in the world now is the
computing environment because of this
this dissipation or this resistance
that's in primarily CMOS is the
technology that's used to build
computers today so an interesting side
effect of what we've built is it will be
very energy efficient in fact not not
using any power at all other than the
power it takes to drive the refrigerator
and the equipment that goes along with
that but that'll be a relatively modest
fixed heat load so there are other there
are even other types of quantum
computers that people are building
Microsoft has a really interesting
project going on where they're trying to
develop what's called a topological
quantum computer and it's a yet another
type of quantum computer and that is a
very interesting and some scientists
computer scientists are very excited
about the potential there the problem is
that type of computing will require the
discovery of a particle called a non
abelian any on which which physicists do
believe exists but they haven't actually
been able to identify one so once they
identify that particle then they could
start to think about how they would
build the hardware to harness that
particle and and so on so that's a you
know probably a very long term effort in
order to build something like that
maybe decades so the the inspiration of
our founders were really let's get to
market with something that can deliver
real benefit to the computing users of
the world as soon as possible and they
made that decision more than 10 years
ago and we've been implementing that
ever since and I think that's put us in
a good position and that's why we've
been able to deliver to our customers on
partners today